COMPASSION, THERE IS ZERO
EMPATHY IN ANY OF THAT.
HERE WITH EXCLUSIVE REACTION,
TONIGHT FOR THE DNC,
DONALD TRUMP JR. EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION.
DON, I WENT TO PLAY THIS MOMENT
FROM JOE BIDEN TONIGHT.
>> THIS IS A LIFE-CHANGING
ELECTION.
THIS WILL DETERMINE WHAT AMERICA
WILL LOOK LIKE FOR A LONG, LONG
TIME.
CHARACTERS ON THE BALLOT,
COMPASSION IS ON THE BALLOTS,
DECENCY, SCIENCE, DEMOCRACY,
THEY ARE ALL ON THE BALLOT.
>> Laura: THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
PLAN.
THAT WAS REALLY THE THEME OF THE
WEEK, NO POLICY, JUST DECENCY
OVERLOADED.
MEANING IS THAT YOUR DAD DOESN’T
HAVE ANY OF THE DECENCY OR
COMPASSION THING.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW, I DON’T
THINK SO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
EXPECT RESULTS FROM THEIR
POLITICIANS.
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN A 50 YEAR
SLUMP CREATURE AND HE WAS
ELECTED INTO THE D.C. OFFICE IN
HIS 20s.
NOW, HALF A CENTURY LATER, LAURA
LAURA, HE MANAGED TO READ A
SPEECH ON THE TELEPROMPTER, HE
REFUSES TO ANSWER QUESTIONS FROM
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WERE
JOURNALIST.
HE HAS BEEN HIDING IN A BASEMENT
BUT NOW HE’S ALSO GOING TO
CHANGE THINGS.
I REALLY DON’T THINK ANYONE
BELIEVES THAT I DON’T THINK THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS EVER BEEN
INSPIRING IN HIS CAREER AND I
DON’T THINK ANY NIGHT WAS
DIFFERENT.
IF YOU CAN READ A SPEECH ON THE
TELEPROMPTER YOU WOULD THINK HE
WOULD BE ABLE TO GET TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT HE WOULD BE
ABLE TO DO AN INTERVIEW WITH A
REAL JOURNALIST WHERE THEY ARE
NOT GIVING HIM PRESCRIPTED
ANSWERS AND READING THE ANSWERS
OFF THE TELEPROMPTER.
WE THINK IT WOULD BE ABLE TO DO
THAT AFTER HALF A CENTURY IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
BUT HE CAN’T.
THE REALITY THAT YOU’VE SEEN
THIS WEEK, THEY HEARD JOE BIDEN,
MICHELLE OBAMA, MAYBE THAT
PERSON SHOULD BE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
THEY’RE NOT INSPIRED BY
JOE BIDEN BECAUSE HE HASN’T DONE
ANYTHING TO DISSERVE INSPIRATION
THROUGH A VERY LONG AND VERY
SWAMPY CAREER.
>> Laura: FOR THE LAST FOUR
DAYS, TOO BAD THEY WERE NOT IN
CHARGE FOR EIGHT YEARS BECAUSE
HE MIGHT MIGHT HAVE DONE ALL THE
COOL STUFF.
WHEN HE DID BEAT THE
EXPECTATIONS AND THAT PEOPLE
WERE EXPECTING HIM TO FLUB EVERY
LINE AND HAVE A SENIOR MOMENT.
JUST THE DELIVERY AND DEVOID OF
ANY POLICY OTHER THAN UNIVERSAL
MASKING, BUT HE DELIVERED A GOOD
SPEECH AND FOR WHAT HE WAS
DOING, VERY EMOTIONAL.
BUT EMOTIONAL STUFF, WALK DOWN
MEMORY LANE AND SO FORTH.
>> HE ALSO LIED, HE BRINGS BACK
THE DEMOCRATS ONLY -- EASY
BUTTON GOING BACK TO THE LINE
ABOUT CHARLOTTESVILLE, TALKED
ABOUT BEING TOUGH ON CHINA.
YOU’RE GOING TO BE TOUGH ON
CHINA NOW?
WHEN JOE STARTED PUSHING AND
SHOVELING FOR THEM TO GET
PERMANENT STATUS IN THE WORLD
TRADE ORGANIZATION, CHINA HAD AN
ECONOMY THE SIZE OF THE
NETHERLANDS.
HUNTER BIDEN, HE DIDN’T TALK TOO
MUCH ABOUT HUNTER STRANGE
ENOUGH, HE TOOK A $1.9 BILLION
FROM THE CHINA GOVERNMENT AND
THE AVERAGE PERSON, THAT’S
$30 MILLION A YEAR IN FEES.
IN FEES!
$30 MILLION A YEAR ANNUALLY AND
YOU THINK IS GOING TO BE TOUGH
ON CHINA NOW?
JOE FIVE FOR NAFTA, JOE FOUGHT
FOR TPP, ALL OF THE DEALS THAT
REALLY DESTROYED THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
OUR ONLY EXPERTS UNDER
JOE BIDEN’S 50 YEAR TENURE HAS
BEEN THE AMERICAN DREAM THE
COUNTRIES THAT HATE OUR GUTS AND
HAVE BEEN MANIPULATING US FOR
DECADES.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE FIRST GUY TO
STAND UP TO THOSE PEOPLE HE’S
THE FIRST GUY TO ACTUALLY GET
THE DEAL DONE WHETHER IT’S WITH
CHINA, WHETHER A PEACE DEAL IN
THE MIDDLE EAST, WHERE IS
JOE BIDEN AND WHERE HE HAS HE
BEEN?
HE WAS IN CONTROL FOR EIGHT
YEARS WITH BARACK OBAMA, WHY DID
THEY NOT DO ANY OF THESE THINGS?
AND JOE BIDEN KNEW HOW TO FIX
ANYTHING, WHY DIDN’T HE TELL A
BARACK OBAMA HOW TO DO IT?
>> Laura: OR BARACK OBAMA WAS
KEEPING IT SECRET TO GIVE TO JOE
FOR LATER USE WHEN HE WAS
RUNNING.
>> IT’S GOING TO BE THEIR SECRET
SO NOW.
AT EIGHT YEARS OF FAILURE, EIGHT
YEARS OF STAGNATION, YOU KNOW,
YOU’RE GOING TO LISTEN TO
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG WHO HAS SPENT
A MILLION DOLLARS TO WIN A
AMERICAN SAMOA, PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO TAKE HIS ADVICE EITHER.
>> Laura: THE ELUSIVE HUNTER
BIDEN SINCE HE MENTIONED HIM,
DON, HE MADE THE APPEARANCE
TONIGHT.
AND TAKE A LOOK.
>> I’M HUNTER BIDEN.
AND I’M ACTUALLY ASHLEY BIDEN.
>> WE WANT TO TELL YOU WHAT KIND
OF PRESIDENT ARE DEAD WILL BE.
>> HE WILL
BE TOUGH.
>> AND HONEST.
>> Laura: DO YOU KNOW HOW THEY
WERE TRADING WORDS UNTIL THE END
UNTIL ASHLEY SAID CARING AND
PRINCIPLED?
DID THEY NOT 100 TO SAY THAT?
>> I DON’T THINK HUNTER AFTER
HIDING FOR SPOUSAL SUPPORT,
CHILD PAYMENTS, ET CETERA,
ET CETERA, AGAIN, NOT TO MENTION
THE CROOKED UKRAINE DEAL, THE
POLITICIAN, CHINESE GOVERNMENT
$1.5 MILLION, NOT ACTUALLY AN
INVESTOR BEFORE.
I DO NOT THINK THAT HUNTER WILL
TALK MUCH ABOUT CHARACTERS IN
THESE THINGS BUT THE REALITY
WHETHER IT’S HUNTER, JOE BIDEN’S
BROTHER, WHETHER IT IS HIS
SISTER, THEY HAVE ALL SPENT
THEIR ENTIRE LIVES PROFITING OFF
JOE BIDEN, TAXPAYER-FUNDED
OFFICES.
THAT IS ALL THEY KNOW AND THAT’S
HONESTLY WHY THEY HAVEN’T HAD
THE DECENCY TO STEP IN AND SAY
HEY, MAYBE NOT YOUR TURN, MAYBE
IT SHOULD NOT BE YOU.
THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE THAT
DURING THE PRIMARY BUT THEY HAVE
NOTHING ELSE.
IT’S THE EPITOME OF THE SWAMP
AND THAT’S WHAT THE ELECTION
WILL COME DOWN TO.
IT’S GOING TO BE THE SWAMP
VERSUS FREEDOM IN AMERICA, IT’S
GOING TO BE SOCIALISM AS YOU
HAVE SEEN WITH THE
BERNIE SANDERS JOINT UNITY
PLATFORM ON JOE BIDEN’S WEBSITE.
IT WILL BE SOCIALISM VERSUS
FREEDOM.
WORSE THAN THE CONSTITUTION AND
ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS DON’T BELIEVE SO MUCH
IN AND YOU ALSO DID NOT HEAR AND
AGAIN, THEY BROUGHT UP THE HOAX,
THE NONSENSE "THEY’VE BEEN ABLE
HE DID THE MEDIA" FOR MONTHS
ABOUT CHARLOTTESVILLE.
IT KNOWS THEY DID NOT TALK ABOUT
THE CRIME AND DEMOCRAT RUN
CITIES, BURNING, LOOTING,
BEATING PEOPLE IN THE STREETS.
JOE IS NEVER EVEN ANNOUNCE THAT
AND THE DEMOCRATS HAVE NEVER
EVEN TO ANNOUNCE THAT IT SEEMS
THAT THEY ARE ALLOWING OF IT,
LAURA.
THEY’RE ALL DEMOCRATS CITIES IN
OVER A CENTURY.
>> Laura: INSTEAD, THE
REFERENCES TO THE CITY WAS
ALWAYS IN TERMS OF WHAT’S IN IT
INSPIRING THAT THESE NEW
VERSIONS OF JOHN LEWIS WERE OUT.
>> PEACEFUL PROTESTERS.
THEY DON’T BURN DOWN CARS,
HOUSING PROJECTS, THEY DON’T
LOOT WHO TO STORES TO GET A NEW
HANDBAG OR PURSE OR A BELT, THAT
IS NOT PEACEFUL PROTESTING.
AND YET BETWEEN THE DNC AND
THEIR MARKETING WITH THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, I HEARD A LOT
ABOUT PEACEFUL PROTESTING AND I
BELIEVE PEOPLE CALLED IT THE
SUMMER OF LOVE.
TO GIVE ME A BREAK.
I HOPE A GOOD GOD-FEARING
AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE THROUGH THIS
NONSENSE BECAUSE THAT IS THE
PROBLEM THAT WE FACE.
WE ARE IN A UPHILL BATTLE IN THE
SENSE THAT IT IS SO BIASED, IT
IS SO FLAGRANT, THAT THE MEDIA
HAS TOTALLY JUST ADVOCATED THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE ARBITERS OF
TRUTH.
WITHOUT BIAS TO BE ACTIVISTS FOR
THE LEFT AND THAT REGULAR PEOPLE
AREN’T CONSUMING THAT SORT OF
NEWS.
JOE BIDEN GETTING TOUGH ON
CHINA, I MEAN, IT IS LAUGHABLE.
>> Laura: IT’S BEYOND
LAUGHABLE.
IT’S THE CHINA QUESTION ALONE.
>> HE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO AN
INTERVIEW LIKE SOMEONE WITH
YOURSELF OR SOMEONE WHO IS NOT
GOING TO SPOON-FEED HIM
QUESTIONS THAT HE ALREADY HAS
THE ANSWER TO THAT HE IS
MIRACULOUSLY LEADING OFF THE
TELEPROMPTER.
I DON’T THINK THEY WILL AND
NOBODY WILL PUSH FOR IT.
>> Laura: DON, YES-OR-NO
ANSWER, DO YOU THINK HE IS GOING
TO DEBATE YOUR DAD, YES OR NO?